avec nos lucie charlebois ministre
délégué à la réadaptation à la
protection de la jeunesse et à la santé
publique dont soi-même charlebois en
soit le centre mais l'arrêt que ferme
ses portes
il faut comprendre madame la ministre
pour 5 pour ceux qui nous écoutent que
autrefois les gens assistés sociaux qui
allaient dans ce genre de thérapie
prenait une partie de leurs chèques et
redonnait une cette partie là de leur
chèque au centre pour financer le
programme on a coupé l'aide sociale pour
ces gens-là dix ans ils sont en thérapie
logis nourrit donc on coupe de plus 400
dollars le manque à gagner pour ces
centres là n'a jamais été compensé
résultat l'association lance un cri
d'alarmé aujourd'hui au premier ministre
indien
et là je cite là c'est pour moi qui le
dit est ce que le québec il devenu si
pauvre qu'il est incapable de sauver les
1500 lits offerts par les organismes
communautaires privés je vous pose la
question est ce qu'on est rendu si
pauvre au québec qu'on laisse aller les
plus démunis moi je vais vous répondre
par la réponse suivante
moi je pense qu'il ya des
questionnements ça il laisse encore eu
de l'aide qui est l'inde qui leur était
proposé de cette aide là vous savez 60
qui ont adressé l'aisne il ya neuf vins
qui ont levé la main qui nous ont
demandé d'être la compagnie de ceux il y
en a six qui ont été vraiment suivi un
qui a décliné l'offre
il y en a un qui est soutenu en ce
moment entre bref tout ça pour vous dire
que il ya ne pas taxer le qui ont
demandé de l'aide alors il doit pas en
voir une si large problématique que ce
quoi que il faut être encore réceptif
est ce qu'on peut faire mieux je mange
toujours de ces petits vaisseaux mélo
mais ceci étant dit comme je dis sur
soixante dix ans jan 6 seulement qu'ils
ont reçu de l'aide et qui ont été
accompagnés et alors certainement un
raisonnement est pourquoi dans certains
centres des personnes y en a qui ne
doivent payer
rien zéro il y en a d'autres qui paye un
pourcentage vous désirez j'ai dormi
notice il ya 15% des sentiers qui a
aucun frais facturés 20% qu'ils
facturent seulement l'admission le
renard reprenait en adoptant sur la
totale d'accord quoi il ya pas de deux
comment se fait-il que les sommes ne
sont pas facturés
au même moment partout sa vie mme
hillary quand une historique aussi que
je ne vais pas relater ici
mais ce que je peux vous dire moi ce qui
m'interesse là c'est les personnes qui
sont à l'intérieur des cellules qui fait
les re localiser ce matin et c'est ce
qu'on s'est attelé à faire mais il reste
qu auparavant vous allez reconnaître
avec vous wac avant les changements à
l'inde sociale les aspects sociaux qui
allaient dans ces maisons là donner une
partie de leurs chèques pour payer leur
leur leur faux leur leur séjour la cause
est d'accord oui cette course est la
protectrice du citoyen d'ailleurs adopté
a signalé qu'elle était favorable au
principe de monsieur hamad
parce que yann y avait une double
paiement il y avait une inéquité pour
les autres le refus de soins de santé
oui oui parce que le double paiement
monsieur le ministre monsieur mambé
l'hébergement il donnait 1500 $ mais 517
$ par mois c'est maintenant 1565 ou
maison de thérapie
maintenant c'est celle là en plus de
recevoir
le montant des assistés sociaux quand on
a un autre site et sociales qui
profitent à d'autres la maison
réadaptation pour présenter lui même
nommé monsieur loi pourquoi l'autre
personne qui est dans un centre de
réadaptation autres pour le lui ait
coupé alors qu'en dépendance on ne l'est
pas est ce qu'on y version aussitôt
vieille de 60 ans a mené par an dit que
c'est bien que l'on soit coupé non plus
mais ce que la directrice de ce centre
là vous explique très clairement
aujourd'hui que c'est qu'avant les
personnes assez social pouvait donner
400 dollars par mois pour financer
centre là et depuis la maison mais
l'afrique n'a pas été compensée résultat
si elle fait réel
la maison ferme ses portes et ça doit
pas lui je peux vous je vais pas vous
induire en erreur le mais je veux jouer
dès que si certains faits le moi je
donnais 20 mille dollars de mon budget
discrétionnaire a mis les rickshaws que
vous ne savez sûrement pas mon collègue
sam hamad a offert 100 mille dollars
pour d argent pour des personnes qui
sont prestataires qui sont sur les lieux
pour justement arriver à trouver un
équilibre et en ce moment on ferme les
portes avant même de recevoir la somme
ce ces montants là c'était enfin ça a
été mis sur la table mois le 20 mille
dollars je le reverrai paul on juge que
c'est suffisant que le budget qu'on
avait des chèques jugée de l'essence
socialiste est de l'ordre de 300 mille
dollars par année mais expliquez moi
pourquoi y en eut que facturent pas du
tout dont un petit peu puis d'autres la
totale
il ya quelque chose qu'il faut au
québec.le il faut qu'on prenne le temps
d'examiner comment on fait les choses et
comment on peut faire mieux que je pense
qu'on est là en ce moment et moi je suis
bien prêt pas regarder bien des choses
mais il faut il va falloir qu'on
m'explique pourquoi il ya différentes
façons de faire différentes maisons ces
ententes sur une chose les nominés
aujourd'hui ces gens là étaient
désemparés pleurer ne comprenais pas où
est passée des gens vulnérables faire
quand on se fait dire choses comme ça
brusquement
moi je me demande où est l'intérêt déjà
parce que j'avais déjà mis six mois qui
étaient là pour relocaliser ces gens là
est ce qu'on leur donnait la chance de
bien faire ça je ne sais pas je te pose
sur place mais il reste que nous on
était là on voulait s'assurer que cette
personne-là obtiendrez des services très
bien madame la ministre charles brault
merci nous avons parlé on va suivre ce
dossier là oui merci beaucoup au revoir
au revoir
avec nous lise bourgault directrice
générale adjointe du championnat rickman
bourgault je vous voyais réagir pendant
l'entrevue il ya beaucoup de choses
beaucoup de questions que la mine
d'abord la mine et sous-entend que vous
étiez mans l'administré c'est totalement
faux il ya eu des problèmes et l'erec
comme dans d'autres santé l'organisation
s'est relevé de weeds une triste
histoire qui est arrivée en mai 2013
avec le départ de l'ex directeur général
mais on est on s'est relevé et on a fait
nos devoirs
mais l'arrêt qui est un centre certifiés
qui répond à toutes les normes qui sont
en vigueur au québec dans les centres de
thérapie nous chimérique
c'est un sens qui est plus spécialisé si
l'on peut dire pour la clientèle
carcéral
notre équipe d'intervenants sont des
gens très spécialisés depuis plusieurs
années et qui donne des services
maintenant ce que l'humanisme le
discours c'est qu'elles répondent pour
monsieur amar j'ai pas vu sa mère
aujourd'hui c'est vrai qu'on a eu de
l'aide mais je les remercie la mairie ça
nous a donné 20 mille dollars
on ne fait que les travaux pour lesquels
nous donner l'argent mais on est allé la
voir on est allé voir ses fonctionnaires
ça fait longtemps qu'ils nous ont dit
qu'ils avaient des maisons qui avaient
trop de maisons québec et que la réforme
de l'aide sociale était pour l'enfermer
on a fait des tableaux je suis allée à
québec avec mon collègue de l'envolée
nicolas bédard
et puis on a fait des tableaux à l'effet
que il y aurait effectivement des
coupures et que le cercle polo aurait
comme conséquence alors le malheur de
mêlée rire aujourd'hui devrait en
principe faire le bonheur d'autres
centres la ministre dit pourquoi
d'autres centres ne charge pas de
demande pas d'argent aux gens qui
viennent les voir quitter thérapie et
pourquoi mais la ric demander de
l'argent aux aspects sociaux qui les
menace doit parler des 660 et 700 qui
sont financés par le cercle la menace de
parler des descend qui entre qui
reçoivent descendent astronomique via le
programme de soutien aux organismes
communautaires
ça fait longtemps qu'on dit aux mines à
la ministre vous n'avez pas compenser la
non charlebois les sommes que monsieur à
manier enlevés donc si justin ministère
de l'emploi et de la solidarité sociale
actuellement qui paient pour les
résidents alors nous on a demandé aux
mondiaux en salle la santé côté le 400 $
qu'on fait sur pu demain que le 150 à
l'admission faut que quelqu'un nous
qu'on pense
bourgault expliquez moi ça à 20
auparavant avant mes derniers oui les
gens qui allaient chez vous de leur
chèque dette sociale qui recevait autour
de 700 ghana 747 il vous remet tait 404
assad alors bon depuis la réforme de
l'aide sociale ils ont été coupées d'à
peu près 400 $ d'écouté à 200 par mois
d'accord il ne vous remettent plus rien
mais n'ont à peu près plus rien ce
manque à gagner l'or vous l'avez à peu
près jamais on n'a pas vu depuis le 1er
mai depuis le 1er mai savez-vous qui
supportent numérique
j'ai bien eu là de mon député qui a
essayé même m'ont dit t'es pas capable
de se faire entendre à ses ministres la
seule personne qui nous ont aidé et là
c'est sûr les hôtes de la fédération des
caisses desjardins
monsieur lamothe d'investissement québec
et françois humbert ii du réseau
d'économie sociale
si le privé qui supportent mais l'arrêt
depuis le 1er mai en pensant que why le
gouvernement va se réveiller bon ils
vont compenser cette somme nos que ce
qui va arriver à ces gens qu'on a vu
dans le reportage dans louise ses exams
qui pleurait qui était désemparé où ils
vont là là ils sont transférés dans
d'autres sources il se laissait sans
emplois perdus mais la rixe et une
expertise unique au québec
et puis aussi la clientèle de buts
alloués à plus de 100 kg ce soir il ya
vingt-cinq personnes qui sont accor
amérique convoquons accueille oui la
mêlée sans raison les genres se sont
tournés dans les services correctionnels
ils ont rencontré des juges aujourd'hui
qu'ils ont acquis a accepté leur
transfert
mais ce que les ministres disposent
c'est que les centres sont payés pour
des familles lic des sommes famélique
pour garder des adultes alors que le
gouvernement paye 60 dollars par jour
pour des services de garde
moi je suis content que les services de
garde mais nous gbh des adultes je les
nourris je les traite et plus souvent ce
qu'on a perdu plusieurs milliers de
dollars par des clients qu'on ne pas été
payés par l'aide sociale bref mais
l'afrique a terminé de faire de prendre
la responsabilité du gouvernement du
québec la limbourgeoise que c'est
terminé terminée
où l'apport des voies de sortie pour
vous l'histoire et est fermé c'est
derrière vous n'y a plus de moyens de
financer votre sommes écoutés on a
demandé 350 m $ alors dans ce cas vous
receviez pendant les jeux ça c'est
l'argent que c'est perdu depuis le 1er
mai nous n'avons pas non on n'est pas
mêlé au sang qui sont financés par le
stock de la manille selon jean-paul 60
pas creuser le ciboulot excusez moi
l'expression pour faire dd des réformes
dans leurs simples et ont une même
montant qui s henri dillies saint élie
zerhouni yassoi groupe sap parfait on
sait qu plus derrière
en terminant est ce que le fait que vous
accompagner la clientèle la plus
vulnérable par les deux prisonniers
parler de jean pauquet est-ce que c'est
moins entre guillemets c'est moi qui
l'aï moins populaire d'avoir du
financement dans ce grand marché de
financement d'oeuvres communautaire
savez-vous à c'est le triste constat que
si tu es aujourd'hui j'ai passé la
journée à voir ce qui en bloque on est
pris dans nos bras aux dizaines sont nos
clients et nous on n'a pas de jugement
ou les accueils même que pisa clients
qui sont venus ont leur rendu des
services sont partis nous ont pas payés
mais c'est quoi les responsabilités d'un
organisme privé que de rendre ces
services le oui en vénérant non vie tu
payes équitablement pour le faire on
leur demandait 10 pièces par jour de
plus pour leur demander de nous
rembourser trois cent cinquante mille
dollars
il y aurait là et c'est çà et là ça fait
des mois qu'ils satisfont pas ce que
vous pensez que tout le monde est
conscient de ce gouvernement couillard
de ce qui se passait et je laisse à l
état paul à lille ils sont moins on le
fait appel à tous les ministres j'ai
même rencontré une squatteuse d'une
hermine liste elle est en bonne et due
forme pour qu'il fasse sa réforme au
niveau du top que cette subvention le
soit équitable à tous les centres qui
offrent des services interactifs et qui
sont subventionnées et qui sont
accrédités par les centres de services
sociaux des laurentides
j'ai mal au coeur aujourd'hui mais là je
suis triste pour les clients que j'ai dû
déplacer aujourd'hui je suis triste
police ait personne qui part en un point
je suis triste police six personnes la
commission scolaire de la
rivière-du-nord qui ont perdu leur job
aujourd'hui il se suis triste pour les
clans tête du terme mais qui ont pu te
sens tu à la cote de proximité vous
savez combien de temps je suis arrivé où
se mêleraient qu'en 2010 lorsque la
région c'est devenu un organisme sans
but lucratif
oui
et tout l'historique les maison de
thérapie ont subi des hauts et des bas
avec la clientèle qu'on accueille c'est
pas une clientèle facile mais c'est
quand même clientèle attachante
on s'est relevé les manches l'équipe a
baissé les salaires on ne baissera au
salaire moi je travaille 60 heures je
payais pour 20 vraiment on a tout ce
qu'il fallait que je refuse les
prétentions qu'on est mal administré et
qu'on ne connaît pas même à l'avenir
c'est la faute du gouvernement depuis le
1er mai 2015 s'il est sans doute été
ratée au québec sont dans les
difficultés financières jeu pour faire
bondir encore mais non je peux vous
laisser partir en vacances vous avez
suivi l'actualité depuis plusieurs mois
vous voyez ce qu'on a donnée aux
médecins ce qu'on donne à bombarder
salon ou faire surchauffer épouvantable
surtout loges moi je le dis encore
dernièrement la nudité d'entreprises
privées sera fermée depuis 1er mai la
lutte était de desjardins ipd
d'investissement québec
mais c'était pouvant atteindre le
contrôle des armes d'épaulé à vos côtés
de fortune le gouvernement d'ottawa
arrêter ça parce que t'es trop cher les
milliards à bombardier ça couine de tous
bords tous côtés
le pauvre monde qui en ont le plus
besoin ce sont leurs demandes 10 dollars
par jour on ne leur demande pas de
chercher du nouveau budget monsieur roy
ils l'ont déjà dans le top 7 millions
six cent soixante sept mille qui par un
stage en halo pikine où tu nous donnes
ya dix heures par jour etc stablement
tous les centres qui sont certifiés qui
est tout le monde est content puis leurs
warrants des services au gouvernement
c'est le gouvernement qui parle qui vous
parle c'est que par le gouvernement et
la société qui perd mais à un moment
donné il faut que quelqu'un ferme pour
ces mêmes ça marche au québec 1 on a
beau sonner la cloche on a beau aviser
tout le monde na c'est un moment donné
c'est parce qu'elle robben que l'on voit
le monde se réveille
ouais lise bourgault merci merci
beaucoup de votre pain sans merci dans
la série mercy